when it comes to fish oil um
i still think it's not a terrible idea
to have some epa and dha coming into
your diet
for a variety of reasons unrelated to
building muscle getting stronger losing
fat i think when you look at the various
roles of epa and dha in physiology
it's hard to view more epa and dha in
your system as a particularly negative
thing within within reasonable
boundaries so
uh generally speaking you'll see a lot
of review papers focused on general
health and wellness that say hey
try to get like 0.3 to 0.5 grams a day
of combined epa and dha that could come
from fish oil it could come from algae
oil you know whatever you prefer
it's still unclear from my perspective
if higher doses will lead to any
tangible benefits that relate to
lifting recovery hypertrophy fat loss
anything of that nature but i still
think it's a good idea to seek out some
epa and dha in your diet for completely
unrelated reasons so i'd say 0.3 to 0.5
grams per day on average doesn't doesn't
mean you have to get that every day but
over the course of a week you know if
you're averaging that intake per day
that's probably a good place to be if
you want to go a little bit higher i
think it's pretty reasonable to go up to
like one
maybe even up to two grams a day two two
i think is kind of the highest end for
me where i'd say yeah that makes a lot
of sense um there are some select
instances where you might wanna go
higher but i haven't really seen strong
enough evidence to convince me that more
than one or two grams a day of combined
epa and dha would really be
uh
an important thing to do or a tangibly
beneficial thing to do and the caveat
that i always like to point out here
if you are taking relatively high doses
of epa and dha
it can increase bleeding time so so like
if you were to you know have a wound uh
that bleeding might not stop quite as
quickly if you were taking high doses of
fish oil so like for instance if you
were going in for a surgery or something
like that you would absolutely want to
make sure that your medical team knows
that you've been taking epa and dha so
all of that is to say epa and dha are
still very interesting
[Music]
components of the diet i still think you
want to sink seek them out
but i don't think you want to seek them
out as a
potent anabolic
dietary ingredient
more research i'm sure will be done that
will clarify some of these unresolved
questions about promoting hypertrophy
and uh promoting acute recovery but for
now there's just not as much uh exciting
evidences as you'd like to believe
unfortunately